let's follow up to this story where
Donald Trump started to reset and pivot
his campaign by suggesting his
supporters maybe use their guns to kill
Hillary Clinton as a back story if you
missed yesterday's show here's the video
clip of Trump making the suggestion at a
rally Hillary wants to abolish
essentially abolish the Second Amendment
by the way and if she gets to pick if
she gets to pick her judges nothing you
can do folks
although the Second Amendment people
maybe there is I don't know but but I'll
tell you what that will be a horrible
day a couple updates on this number one
there was that guy in the red shirt
behind Trump during that speech that I
pointed out yesterday who seemed shocked
or to be loving it CNN actually
interviewed him and he said oh I'm
voting Trump so he clearly was not so
disgusted with that suggestion that he's
not voting Trump that's number one
number two yesterday I said imagine
being in the Secret Service right you're
not you're non-political organization
you're there to protect the candidates
and one candidate says something that
could endanger the other candidate what
do you do according to CNN you have a
conversation with the campaign CNN is
reporting that a US Secret Service
official has confirmed that the Secret
Service spoke to the Trump campaign
about those comments saying there has
been more than one conversation the
campaign said that the you they said to
the US Secret Service that Donald Trump
did not mean to incite violence that is
the report that we have seen and in
response to CNN's report Trump tweeted
that no meeting took place that no
conversation took place and then the
latest is that Reuters says well no
formal discussion took place with the
Secret Service so I think here the key
word Luis is formally there has not been
anything denied that some conversation
took place between the Secret Service
and the Trump campaign it appears that
that could be true while Simas
simultaneously of maintaining that there
was no formal conversation with Donald
Trump personally I don't know but
if I were in the Secret Service I would
certainly be talking to Donald Trump
about this I don't know why it's hard to
believe that the Secret Service might
have heard this and said oh yeah we
should talk to the campaign about it
yeah I'm just wondering what that
conversation was I'm pretty sure that no
one is actually threatened by by Donald
Trump himself and no one in the Secret
Service thinks Donald Trump is gonna go
on a shooting rampage now but it was
probably just something along the lines
of I just don't say things like that
right yeah just just stop we know that
there are constantly death threats
against political candidates against
elected officials etc and part of what
these agencies like the Secret Service
have to do is evaluate what is a
credible threat and what isn't they take
all threats very seriously
if you have one of the two major party
candidates saying something that could
encourage more of those death threats
which then need to be looked into and
explored that's not good for anybody
it's just more more work for the Secret
Service that could potentially be
avoided so they can actually focus on
doing what it is they're really supposed
to do which is not protect one candidate
from the people that might go after them
based on the suggestions made by the
other candidate now last thought on this
this morning I saw a Trump rally or a
Trump speech I guess you would call it
at the Home Builders Association in
Florida something like that he seemed
very very low-energy I know that's what
he would call Jeb Bush during the
campaign I think something happened over
the last 24 hours that may have put
Trump over some kind of edge he showed
up with absolutely no energy he held up
a couple of charts that he had printed
out it was palpably lacking the vigor
that we have seen from Trump over the
last several months he may really be
starting to fall apart here this is a
taxing a taxing schedule I'm sure it's
possible that he was just exceptionally
tired yeah that day or this is what
Donald Trump is normally like and every
other time he's on some type of powerful
stimulant yeah I don't know which it is
but noticeably different this morning
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
SiC games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3
Wii and a bunch of other platforms and
you can play as many games as you want
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s